I can't help how my heart feels finding
love on a reality TV show isn't always
easy and no one knows that better than
you of Brad Womack you surprised us all
in season 11 of The Bachelor when you
rejected both of your final contestants
and then in season 15 you finally found
love with Emily Maynard or so you
thought
Emily went on to try her hand on the
Bachelorette and you gave up on finding
love on reality TV shows
it's from every woman in America Brad
Womack might have thrown in his towel
but the same can't be said for these ten
contestants some of these ladies are
still trying to get the final rose on
The Bachelor
keep watching to find out which
contestant has starred in over four
seasons Amber James they say that the
third time's a charm but that isn't the
case for contestant amber James who
tried to win the final rose a total of
three times
isn't that catty and crazy as it looks
on yes amber was a bartender from
Kankakee Illinois when she first
appeared on season 19 of The Bachelor in
2015 this season featured the then 33
year-old Chris soules a farmer from
Arlington Iowa but it just wasn't meant
to be between the farmer and the
bartender and Chris sent amber packing
in week three
that same year amber made a comeback in
the second season of the spin-off series
bachelor in paradise and while amber
managed to last more than three weeks
this time around she was eliminated in
week 5 but that wasn't enough to stop
amber from trying her hand one last time
in 2016 amber appeared in season 20 of
The Bachelor but this time around she
was competing for bachelor Ben Higgins
heart then was a software salesman from
Warsaw Indiana and things seemed
promising at first
unfortunately for amber Ben would send
her home in week four it's not working
clearly Becca Tilly just like Amber
James Becca Tilly tried to snag Chris
soules heart in season 19 of The
Bachelor and while she surpassed her
fellow contestant she didn't make it to
the finish line the chiropractic
assistant from San Diego California had
an instant connection with Chris but
when things got a little shaky when the
Bachelor found out that Becca had never
been in a serious relationship
chip before appearing on the show Becca
was the season's runner-up but in the
end Chris chose Whitney Bischoff over
her in the final rose ceremony fans of
the series were surprised to see not one
but two familiar faces in the following
season of The Bachelor both Becca and
amber returned determined to make Ben
Higgins fall in love with them but
things didn't go as planned this time
around Becca made it into the final six
but she was sent home by The Bachelor in
week 7 scary to not have the same words
that bad
today Becca has revealed that she would
much rather keep her romantic life
private if the reality TV star is dating
anyone she's keeping it under wraps
I just am in a place where I'm like
keeping it personal Jubilee sharp
Jubilee sharp isn't someone who's shied
away from the camera she's gorgeous and
brave which is why she's appeared in the
season of The Bachelor as well as two
seasons of The Bachelor in paradise
Jubilee is a war veteran from Fort
Lauderdale Florida and in 2016 she went
head-to-head with both amber and Becca
in season 20 of The Bachelor Jubilee
made it into the top 12 and got to
travel to Mexico City with Ben and the
other contestants however she was sent
home in week 5 when Ben's last rose was
offered to Olivia karidian stead that
same year Jubilee was offered a spot in
season 3 of the spin-off series bachelor
in paradise the veteran turned model
returned to Mexico to film the series
unfortunately Jubilee would be sent home
in the very first week but that didn't
stop her from trying to find love in
season 5 of bachelor in paradise you
know what they say there's no love
without war this time however Jubilee
would quit the show in week 3 she chose
to leave the show when she found out
that John didn't want to date her and
since she wasn't interested in anyone
else she said her goodbyes and went back
home what are you doing here Demi
Burnett Debbie Burnett isn't your
average blonde bombshell she's a country
girl at heart and she loves driving
around in her ATV fishing and watching
WWE she's an interior designer from red
oak Texas and she's got tons of sass
which sort of rubbed her fellow
contestants the wrong way in 2019 Demi
first appeared in season 23 of The
Bachelor she came on strong from the get
which was both intriguing and
off-putting for Colton Underwood the
seasons charitable bachelor Colton was a
former professional football player from
Washington Illinois
Dimmie added a lot of drama to the
season going as far as calling it Demi
season of The Bachelor but in the end
Colton just didn't see Demi as wife
material thank you for being honest so
he sent her home in week six the dimi
wasn't about to give up so easily that
same year she returned for the sixth
season of bachelor in paradise
Demi would go on to be named this
season's winner she got engaged to
girlfriend Christian Haggerty but there
was trouble in paradise and the couple
announced their split in late October of
2019 if you love The Bachelor and all of
its spin-offs you're going to love the
things so hit that subscribe button and
click the bell to be notified as soon as
we post a new video if you're watching
on your phone or tablet
make sure to switch up your YouTube
settings so you never miss another video
now let's find out which former
contestant is still trying to find love
on The Bachelor
viviana Julianne Viviana Julien's a
sucker for love which is why she
appeared in a total of four different
seasons of The Bachelor The Bachelor
Winter Games and bachelor in paradise we
first encountered Viviana in season 22
of The Bachelor the season aired in 2018
and had girls competing to be re only on
dick Junior's fiance Bibiana was a
feisty competitor who would be sent home
in week three that same year Viviana
would try her luck on The Bachelor
Winter Games
every time one door shuts the other
opens but the Executive Assistant from
Miami Florida would be eliminated in
episode 4 then in the summer of 2018
viviana would be invited to compete in
season five of bachelor in paradise
alongside Jubilee but Viviana's attitude
wouldn't be well-received by her fellow
mates which would get her sent home in
week 2 the following summer in 2019
Bibiana would test the waters one last
time on season 6 of bachelor in paradise
however this would prove to be her worst
season yet as the former Miami Dolphins
cheerleader would get booted off the
show after just one week
mic drop henna Brown beauty queen henna
Brown is an unapologetic serial dater
who has been looking for love on reality
TV since 2019 she's an interior designer
from Tuscaloosa Alabama and she recently
made a surprise comeback on season 24 of
The Bachelor this charming country girl
first appeared on season 23 of The
Bachelor
she stole Colton Underwood's heart from
the very beginning but their romance
wouldn't last
Colton Santana packing in week 7 and she
was devastated but she was given the
second chance that same year when she
made headlines as the new Bachelorette
of season 15 cannon would go on to give
Jed Wyatt her final rose but this proved
to be a very bad choice considering that
dad had his secret girlfriends back home
Hannah never did find the men of her
dreams however she always regretted
sending pilot Pete home in week nine so
when it was announced that Peter Weber
would be the bachelor of season 24
Hannah agreed to make a surprise
comeback on the show as of January 2020
the tables have turned and now Hannah is
competing for one of Peters roses what
do you what do you want
I'm so confused now however some
bachelor fans aren't too happy about
Hannah's surprise appearance in the
premiere are you happy that Hannah is
back sound off in the comments Kaitlyn
Bristowe and season 19 of The Bachelor
we were introduced to Kaitlyn Bristowe
a fun-loving dance instructor from
Alberta Canada Kaitlyn was a finalist
who would be eliminated by Chris soules
and week 9 but ABC wouldn't be done with
Kaitlyn just yet after all she was a
total catch shortly after Kaitlyn was
sent home it would be announced that
Britt Milson and herself would compete
to be the Bachelorette for the 11th
season of the spin-off series this
season would be unlike any other and the
male contestants on The Bachelorette we
get to vote between two women breath who
had been eliminated by Chris and week
seven would go head to head to become
the next Bachelorette but in the end the
men voted for Kaitlyn Kaitlyn would go
on to get engaged to shawn booth however
the couple never tie the knot and
eventually announced their split today
Kaitlyn lives in Nashville with her
boyfriend Jason tar Tech who was a
contestant on season 14 of The
Bachelorette
Christina show
Christina Schulman is a hopeless
romantic who was determined to find love
in season 21 of The Bachelor sadly
things didn't exactly go as planned
christina competed for bachelor nick
Vile's final rose in 2017 but the
software sales executive from wisconsin
that couldn't picture a life with her so
nick eliminated her in week 7 but that
didn't stop her from trying to find love
in seasons 4 and 6 of bachelor in
paradise
in 2018 christina had a very
heartbreaking run on paradise
Christina's heart was broken by Dean
englert's a player who kept bouncing
back and forth between Christina and
another contestant
as a result Christina chose to leave the
show in week three I understand here so
I want to say my advice but she remained
optimistic and agreed to make a comeback
in season six of paradise in 2019 but
history repeats itself and Christina
once again chose to quit the show this
time however she lasts until week five
before packing up and going home
Tashia Adams there's no doubt about it
teshia Adams was one of the best
contestants from season 23 of The
Bachelor it's no wonder she found
herself amongst the top three finalists
the medically trained Californian was a
fan favorite who would return for the
sixth season of bachelor in paradise in
2019 but things got a little complicated
for her when she tried to win Blake's
heart on the show although she didn't
come out on top fans would love to see
her become the next Bachelorette ashley
Giacometti and then there's ashley
Iaconelli a contestant who would go on
to compete on The Bachelor
and it's mini spin-offs a total of four
times you went to Paradise twice mm-hmm
Ashley was determined to find the love
of her life on the show which is
something she managed to accomplish
while off camera Ashley is a journalist
from Great Falls Virginia she first
appeared on season 19 of The Bachelor
and managed to stay on Crystal's radar
until she was eliminated in week six
shortly after Ashley would appear on
season two of bachelor in paradise
however she chose to call it quits in
week 5 when she failed to win
Jared havens hearts she tried to do this
again in season 3 of paradise but came
up short and was eliminated in week six
things were looking up for Ashley when
she won The Bachelor Winter Games in
2018 it was here that Ashley
and fell for Kevin went I may finally
the pair dated but never got engaged
choosing to end the relationship weeks
after the after-show first aired but to
everyone's great surprise Ashley
rekindled her relationship with Jared
Haven years after competing for his
heart on paradise Ashley finally found
her happily ever after and Jared and the
happy couple got married in August of
2019 and that's a wrap on the 10
Bachelor contestants who competed more
than once which former contestants would
you want to see on The Bachelorette and
why tell us in the comments thanks for
watching the things and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time
[Music]
you